so hello and welcome to yet another
episode of biographics I'm your interim
host Carl Smallwood that's Carl with a K
and Smallwood with an SM ma l w o d and
today we're talking about Charlotte cord
the angel of assassination and before we
get on to the body of today's video I
should point out that like with all
videos here at biographics this one is
based on a script submitted To Us by a
member of our writing team that member
today being Arnaldo Tani go follow them
on the Social Links below if you are so
inclined also because this is a video
about a French person from France and
there a lot of French words and
pronunciations I've done my best to
familiarize myself with the more
difficult French pronunciations but as
someone from the north of England for
the ones that I'm really really not
familiar with and I couldn't find any
definitive pronunciation guides on I'm
just going to do what all British people
do in my situation they just butcher it
affect an offensive French accent and
try and model through without further
Ado let's get to it
though so it's one of the most famous
works of art of the 18th century painted
by French artist jaac Lou David see what
I did there told you and if you take a
look at the painting you'll see a man
sitting in a bathtub slump slightly to
his right in his hands clutch lightly
the instruments of his profession and of
his power a pen and a letter a small
wound just below the right collarbone
uses Blood on the floor we can see the
murder weapon a stained knife the image
is realistic yet solemn it conveys the
dignity even in death of the man
portrayed his name was Jean Paul morat a
friend of the artists later hailed as a
Marty of the French Revolution just
outside the confines of the frame though
the drama is not over yet a young woman
has been beaten struck with a chair and
thrown to the ground and until that very
afternoon that woman was a young and
sheltered Aristocrat whose involvement
with the politics of the French
Revolution was limited mainly to heater
drawing room discussions well this
afternoon that woman has decided to take
action and strike at a man who in her
eyes represents tyranny her name is
Charlotte cord later immortalized by the
auor alfons D Martin as a brave and
gracious Angel enacting God's Own
Justice the angel of assassination the
Daydream marieanne Charlotte de cord
diamont which we're going to be
shortening to Charlotte cord mainly for
for me it's mainly for me was born on
the 27th of July 1768 in aor Normandy
northern France she was the third of
five children signed by Francois and
Charlotte Senor these two just happen to
be cousins both descendants of P corneal
one of the greatest French playwrights
in spite of this remarkable ancestry
franois was always a strapped for cash
as a third born Sony inherited little
land but he had spent what little money
he had on his children's education The
Works of corneal played a fundamental
role in Charlotte's education as she
admired his selfless Heroes who were
always willing to sacrifice themselves
for the greater good Charlotte's dad
also introduced to the work of
philosophers monu and Russo which
contributed to her political awareness
and a propensity for Progressive
thoughts at least Progressive by the day
standards from an early age Charlotte
talked to daydreaming about
accomplishing some spectacular deed a
feat of arms and courage fueled by
abnation a spirit of self-sacrifice and
a service to a higher ideal of truth
justice and the French way I suppose if
we have given the impression of a
bookworm who only acted through
imagination we do apologize in fact
Charlotte was a vivacious and active
girl almost turbulent while she was
expected to keep her fragile mother and
delicate sister's company she preferred
to play outdoors with her brothers and
The Local Peasant boys this idilic phase
of her childhood however did not last
long in 1782 Charlotte Sor died leaving
franois in a quandry when he was tight
really tight and he could not possibly
look after all of his children his only
choice was to instead then UST them to
the care of a religious institutions
such as the Abbey of the ladies in K
Normandy specifically this institution
was created to take care of aristocratic
yet somehow destitute young ladies like
Charlotte and this is where Charlotte
spent most of her formative years most
of the education she received was of as
you probably guessed a religious nature
quite naturally but the young Mother
Superior Cal decter malan took Charlotte
under her Wing supplying her with
philosophical and political books that
the girl loved ever so much the young
cord day was a guest at the Abby until
the February of 1791 shortly after the
religious orders had been suppressed and
all of the clergy's property
nationalized this upheaval was one of
the consequen of a little event you may
have heard of more than C Day the French
Revolution and just we will not get into
the details of this momentum event of
world history but here are the basics
we've probably also covered it on our
sister Channel Geographics the starting
date in the French Revolution is
generally indicated as July 14th 1789
when the people of Paris stormed the
bastile prison the symbol of Royal
Oppression this act had been the result
of a long simmering tension between the
so-called third Estates or commoners and
other two Estates the aristocracy and
the clergy the lines were not so neatly
drawn though however several members of
the clergy and aristocracy and upper
middle classes did sympathize with the
lower wrongs of the 30 State and the
desire for constitutional reforms this
was particularly true in the economics
department where reforms were really
necessary to Cur the disastrous effects
of the incompetent King Louis the 16's
absolute R the king oscillated between
agreeing to a constitutional government
while conspiring to crush it the new
government had reason to feel threatened
both by internal and external enemies as
monarchist sympathizers and foreign
powers lined up to crush the revolution
in its infancy so despite her
aristocratic Charlotte cord was
sympathetic from the start with the
Revolutionary ideals which she defended
fiercely against more conservative
fellow NS and relatives one of them
Frederick decord would later recall her
energy independence of thought and
single-mindedness stating and I quote
you could not change her mind it was
useless she never had doubts never
uncertainties her decisions once taken
she no longer admitted any contradiction
after the Abby was shut down in 1791
Charlotte returned to let's call it the
the real world moving back to her
father's Farm the 23-year-old
supplemented her father's Mega incor by
tutoring the local children Charlotte
developed something of a reputation as a
skilled and caring teacher beloved by
her own pupils but once she returned
home the dining table became a
battlefield charlot and her father would
engage in Endless heated arguments
during which she stly defended the
Revolutionary ideals against her
father's conservative views eventually
Charlotte could take it no longer and in
June 1791 she went to live with an
elderly relative based in K this elderly
relative had never met Charlotte before
but be grudgingly accepted to take her
in she must have later regretted a
decision as she immediately tried to
marry her off to any Tom Dick or Harry
in the city Charlotte would have
approximately none of this as her
suitors paled in comparison to the
idealized heroes that spoke directly to
her from the pages of the book she'd
read moreover this relative frequent
environment supportive of an absolute
monarchy which only fueled charlott's
stubborn Pro constitutional TI rates
thus far Charlotte's involvement with
the revolution consisted almost
exclusively of heated discussions
against the provincial backrop but
assume the threads of Fate would extend
towards her dragging this FY yet
innocent Norman girl into the grinding
coogs of
history in June 1793 Charlotte's life in
the K Backwater was shaken to the core
by the influx of a band of very
argumentative neighbors we've all been
there a group of about 20 members of
parliament had moved into the htel de
intendance very close to Charlotte's and
her elderly relativ residence these
politicians belonged to a party known as
the ganine and had escaped Paris in
haste after an Insurrection of flared up
on May 31st Charlotte was in a word
delighted to meet a group of such
important revolutionaries and listen
avidly to their discussions the more
time she spent with them however the
more the ideals of Revolution were
shattered the young cord day was well
informed about the power politics within
the Revolutionary Parliament roughly
split into two main parties the guines
and the monards known as the Jacobins
the latter were a alt together more
radical faction who counted the
notorious maximilan Rober the air
amongst their ranks these were the guys
who were the main proponents of just
abolishing the monarchy and they were
all for the centralization of the
economy and civil service and were
inclined to Violent action on the other
hand Charlotte's new friends the
guanines were more moderates they were
ambivalent towards the elimination of
the monarchy advocated for economic
liberalism and oppos the centralization
of government they supported violent
action only if directed against external
enemies for example they urged a
declaration of war against Austria in
April of 1792 after an initial position
of strength the guines had gradually
lost credibility as they were still in
support of a constitutional monarchy but
Louis the 16th committed a series of
blunders starting with a botched escape
attempt in June 1791 which led to his
eventual deposition and Declaration of
the Republic on September 21st 1792
despite the best efforts of the Guin to
save him the King was eventually
guillotined on January 21st 1793 and
that is a word that I do know how to
pronounce thank you Pokémon a monard
delegate was a particularly vocal
supporter of such measures
congratulating the executioners from the
page of his newspaper his name was Jean
Paul
morat Charlotte cord learned about John
Paul morat's misdeeds over the course of
several meetings with girand deine
refugees they told her that after the
events of September 1792 the guine saw
morat as a dangerous radical figure and
brought into trial in April of 1793 but
the tactic sort of backfired morat was
acquitted and the gin's downfall from
Power accelerated yet further morat then
instigated a series of vicious political
attacks against the guines which
culminated with the Insurrection of the
31st of May 1793 a Parisian mob
surrounded the Parliament and demanded
that 29 girine delegates be brought to
trial this is when most of them managed
to escape the riots and eventually fled
to K befriending the young Charlotte
cord the hero of today's story The
24-year-old listened gidle to the girand
dean's recollection of events and that
Tales of persecution painted a very
clear picture in her head the monards
were corrupting the very essence of the
re Evolution replacing tyranny with
worse tyranny and the violist of his
Click Of Death spots was the Jean Paul
morat a liar who spread in Justice from
the pages of his newspaper during one of
these meetings she heard one of the gine
delegates exclaim and I quote let
morat's head roll and the country will
be saved cord a couldn't agree
more on July 9th Charlotte had made up
her mind morat had to die and die by her
hand she left K immediately reaching on
the 11th and she went to a sympathetic
ginding delegate from which she learned
that Jean Paul Marat was now very seldom
seen in public it wasn't widely known
but he had contracted a very painful
skin infection which forced him to take
very long medicinal bath prepared by his
wife Simona vad this was an annoying
snag Charlotte had intended to murder
morat in full view of the public
preferably while he was speaking in
Parliament but it was just a minor snag
after all the show had to go on and
killing a guy in his bathtub is still a
pretty visual image that people are
going to remember July 13th 1793 was a
Sunday and early in the morning
Charlotte took a stroll through Paris on
a shopping trip like many French ladies
do she first bought a fashionable black
hat decorated with a silk green ribbon
then she stopped at a Cutler shop to
purchase what she really needed a big
knife later in the day she barded a
carriage and asked the driver to take
her to the home of Jean Paul morat cord
reached morat's house at 11:30 in the
morning and as she climbed the stairs
leading to the Flats on the first floor
Charlotte was interrupted by Catherine
Simone's Sister Charlotte was told that
Marat was simply too ill to receive
visitors and she had to return to her
lodgings while there she had two notes
dispatched to Marat claiming that she
wanted to discuss sensitive information
regarding an anti- monard plot being
hatched in K she then prepared for her
meeting with morat cord called for a
hairdresser changed into an elegant
dress and finally took to her KN her
birth certificate and a letter addressed
to the French people down the front of
her undergarments too impatient to wait
for a reply to her note she call for
another carriage and by 7 in the evening
she was once again at morat's house this
time Simone blocks her way resulting in
a heated R Charlotte protested loudly
that she wanted to inform citizen Marat
about the goine plots in Normandy and
the ruse Works morat called from his
bath and asked Charlotte to sit next to
his tub which doubled at his writing
desk people don't know yeah he did a lot
of his writing in his in his in his bath
and morat would even say it's a really
great place because no one wants to meet
with you in your bath unless you really
insist upon it so no one bothers me
which fair play a Frenchman to the end I
suppose under Simone's watchful ey
Charlotte talks at length about the
alleged plot naming several actual
gandin along the way names which morat
took careful note of when Simone left
the room to fetch a medicinal powder
morat looked at the list of names and
said and I quote I will have them all
guillotined in Paris it was that point
that Charlotte cord Rose to her feet
Drew her knife and plunged it into
morat's chest just above the right
collarbone no that's the left just above
the right collarbone she then grabbed
the incate list and threw it into the
bathtub hoping that the water would
destroy it and with his dying breath
morat howled for help Simone promptly
arrived followed by Lauren bass an
employee of moratz Charlotte did not
offer any resistance nonetheless Lauren
hits her violently with a chair and then
pinned her to the ground it's not a
steel chair according to historical
sources but I really can't miss an
opportunity to say and then she came in
with the steel chair a police
commissioner citizen gulad soon arrived
to formally arrest Charlotte cord calmly
and bravely admitted to Gard that she
had killed morat by her own hand with
absolutely no outside help whatsoever
interrogators were incred surely a young
well-bred woman was incapable of such an
unspeakable Act of Cruelty and violence
she must have been manipulated by one or
more male conspirators possibly by a
lover finally in the dead of night
Charlotte was transferred to the ab
prison barely escaping the clutches of a
furious mob she was kept in solitary
confinement as authorities tried to make
her confess that she was she must have
been part of a girine conspiracy
preferably a much larger one with more
people they could Guillotine her
interrogator was the president of the
Revolutionary tribunal jacqu Montaine
again cord calmly confessed to her crime
admitted premeditation montin suspected
that she had to have been helped by two
gendan accomplices Deputy D per and
Bishop fosche in the Magistrate's view
such an assassination could not have
been conceived by and I quote a person
of her age and gender to which cord
Riley replied it's easier to carry out
such a project from one's own hatred
from that of
others the following day the 15th of
July the Angelic assassin was
transferred to the con ay prison as she
awaited her trial she wrote two letters
the first was a rather peculiar request
addressed to the committee of the
general safety stating since I only have
a few moments to live might I hope
citizens that you allow me to have my
portrait painted if you Dain to attend
to my request I would ask that you send
me tomorrow a painter of Miniatures the
committee was headed by Robert sperre
notoriously more interested in cutting
off heads than having them portrayed and
he and his colleagues complied
nonetheless and an artist monor how was
sent to the conciergerie the second
letter was addressed to her father in
which she asked for forgiveness stating
in part for disposing of my life without
your permission in this letter Charlotte
also made mention of her lawyer guian
deputy and this is just a lot of French
so Lou Gustav duet count of pony
[Music]
Kant but on the day of the trial July
17th dulet did not show up the public
prosecutor the mon antoan fville had
been tasked sing the defense lawyer via
letter but this message was delivered
too late for dual set to participate
Charlotte would not be without Council
however her defense would have been
taken up by a very famous lawyer of the
time Claude shvak lagard and a curious
parallel history here the same
prosecutor and attorney would actually
face each other in court some months
later during the trial of Marie antoinet
but getting back to cord's case now
shavo lagard may have been a star lawyer
but there was really little he could do
to defend Charlotte cord she had been
caught in the act literally red-handed
and I've only just now realized what
red-handed means with like know blood on
your hands and had confessed several
times to the murder so during the trial
each deposition of the witnesses for
prosecution were met by cord's words
it's true truly a nightmare for any
lawyer finally she admitted to the
tribunal that anything was justified for
the security of the nation I killed one
man in order to save a thousand and yeah
just having like you know your client
constantly shout it's true every time
the prosecution says they did something
probably didn't help with the jury all
her lawyer could really do then was look
for extenuating circumstances namely and
to quote the exaltation of political
fanaticism that had put the dagger into
her hand he in this vein asked the
citizens of the jury to apply prudence
and take into account this and I quote
once again moral consideration in the
balance of Justice the trial started at
8:00 a.m. and was over by the early
afternoon the verdict predictably was a
guilty one the sentence death by
guillotine to be carried out that very
same day at 6:30 p.m. under a heavy rain
Charlotte Cain was taken to the place
deer rolu her hair now cut short and her
elegant dress replaced by a simple red
shirt as she climbed the steps to the
guillotine the execution of Sanson steps
in front of her hoping to hide the
machine of death from her view Charlotte
ordered him to please step aside stating
please I have never seen a guillotine
before and I'm curious to know what it
looks like moments later the heavy blade
had done its job and I'm reminded here
of again another curious historical
parallel when Marie an twet was killed
um her reported last words were excuse
me when she stepped on her executioner
turn on the way to the guillotine
getting back finally to Charlotte cord
one of sanson's assistants a man called
lros had lifted Charlotte's head from
the basket and slapped her cheeks as a
last to Front The Executioner and the
crowd moved by the dignity and courage
she displayed till the literal very end
loudly threatened the man Charlotte may
have killed one of their leaders but she
had eventually earned their respects by
simply being just so baller and Cavalier
about the whole thing the angel of
assassination had serenely accepted the
ultimate consequence of her Mission but
it's worth asking was her Mission a
successful one that note she threw into
the bath yeah they fished that out
almost immediately and got all the names
off it and one of them even commented
after the fact when they were all
tracked down and tried she has killed us
but at least she has showed us how to
die on a larg scale Jean Paul morat's
death did prompt his fellow monards to
crack down hard on the remaining gines
and other enemies of the Revolution
eventually the reaction to the
assassination amongst other external and
internal threats to the revolution
brought about the so-called reign of
terror a period of massacres and public
executions which claimed as many as
27,000 lives cord had stated that she
killed morat to say thousands of Lies
but tragically as fate often likes to do
her deed had the exact opposite effect
and I hope everybody at home enjoyed
this video found it informative
educational and entertaining I certainly
found the script to be all three of
those things and if you do agree alardo
Tani socials can be found below as can
my own if you want to follow me you can
also find our sister channels
Geographics and top 10s which I'm also
the interim host of but as I always like
to say everybody at home like leave a
like below if you like the video a
comment if you got anything to say any
feedback suggestions for future topics
and as always subscribe for more and
have the day you all deserve
cheers